Jewish law states that a body must be
buried within 24 hours of death but not
on the Sabbath which runs from Friday
sunset to Saturday sunset the earliest
record is the Gospel of Mark what mark
says and it's also repeated by Luke and
by John is quite interesting the Joseph
took the body down and then it says
because of the emergency situation that
the holiday that the Passover is so near
hours away on that Friday afternoon that
he put the body in a tomb near the place
of the crucifixion this is the tomb at
Golgotha mentioned in the Gospels
according to the Talmud theory it's a
temporary solution
joseph of arimathea doesn't want to
leave Jesus longer than necessary in a
tomb owned by strangers
that as soon as the festivals over which
would be Saturday night you're going to
come and get that body and put it in a
more permanent location I don't think
it's all the way up in Galilee that's
three days journey to far away and so
it'd be right here in Jerusalem and
eventually others of his family would
join him and that's what we have at
Tokyo this idea that Joseph of Arimathea
took jesus' body from Golgotha to tell
pod is controversial but doesn't
contradict the New Testament
and it does explain why his mortal
remains might be found in a jerusalem
suburb 2,000 years later but what about
the other shocking assertion of the
Talbot theory that Jesus was buried with
a wife and child
how does that stand up to further
scrutiny central to the assessment is
that Jesus was a married man with a son
I mean that is integral to this being a
credible claim this is Jesus the married
man the father buried with other members
of his family in this tomb in South
Europe but is there any evidence in the
Gospels or any other ancient texts to
suggest Jesus as a father
there is no evidence in any early source
whatsoever that Jesus was married to
Mary Magdalene or married to anyone else
in fact in all of our early sources
Jesus is portrayed as a single celibate
Jewish man and so this idea that Jesus
was married is a complete invention of
modern times and none of our Gospels is
there any reference to this at all one
thing to keep in mind though as women
and wives are generally written out of
the history silence means nothing name
Peter's wife Andrews wife James wife any
of the Twelve Apostles they were all
married not a single one do we know the
names of their wives now we can also
talk about a Jewish male age 30 it's
proper to marry and that culture and
that sort of thing in the likelyhood
then that he would be married is there
culturally